[Music]
the forgotten city is a game about
reliving the same day over and over
again uh
salve friend using lessons learned from
your own mistakes in order to construct
the perfect outcome and in the process
break the cycle
it's about getting the chance to do
something all over again until you get
it right which just so happens isn't
that far off of an allegory from the
game's actual development
this is the story of how changing the
setting broke the forgotten city
[Music]
that felt good
oh it's still standing the forgotten
city is a murder mystery stuck in a time
loop set in an intricately designed
roman city constructed with detailed
architecture art wardrobe mythology all
populated with a wide cast of
meticulously detailed characters to
match the era it's so well realized that
if you didn't know you might assume that
the game was always built from the
ground up to be that way however some of
you may actually know that it wasn't in
fact far from it the forgotten city
actually started as a skyrim mod set in
an underground dorban city when designer
writer nick pierce wanted to release it
as a standalone game it would have to
get as far as possible from its original
skyrim setting for
obvious legal reasons so he made one
simple decision
change
the set
the idea was just to sort of neatly
transplant the story from the fantasy
dwarven setting to the ancient rome city
making as few changes as possible
there's one change to the setting
resulted in a series of cascading
changes um you know changes requiring
changes requiring changes that weren't
easy to foresee in the beginning
which resulted in me working about 80
hours a week for for the next four and a
half years at first nick had intended
the whole thing to just take a couple of
years but
as the saying goes
rome wasn't built in a day
or
in two years in this case
the forgotten city mod was released back
in 2015 and was incredibly successful it
resulted in millions of downloads and
even garnered several writing awards
including best interactive media from
the australian writer's guild
nick pierce enjoyed making the mod so
much that he left his established career
as a lawyer to pursue game development
full time and bring the mod to life as a
full-fledged stand-alone game on paper
this ambition appeared achievable it was
meant to be fundamentally a reskin and
i'd seen shakespearean plays where
they'd taken the exact same script and
just transplanted it from you know
hundreds of years ago to present day and
it seemed to work fine for them to be
here not to be
that is the question this new version
would still be a murder mystery and it
would still be a time loop it just
needed a change of scenery just take it
from the underground dwarven city above
ground into a roman setting
easy
i fit in
right you're not from around here are
you if nick was going to change the
setting he wanted to do it right it
needed to be historically authentic so
it didn't just feel like he was plopping
characters into an environment where
they were
out of place so he consulted historians
and over the course of hundreds of video
calls and many emails they laboriously
went over temples mosaics columns and
even agriculture to ensure it was
authentic to the new time period and
setting and the further they got along
the more and more things began to pile
up some of which were not as glaringly
obvious as others like big things like
uh the game's light source and the
physical space where the city is located
for example the chasm is an easy one to
get your head around a key part of the
story is that the city's inhabitants are
trapped there so it had to be redesigned
so characters couldn't just simply climb
out of the top or walk off into the
distance to their freedom but then there
was the game's light source in the mod
the city had been illuminated by one
single sort of science fiction globe
at the top of this cabin um but because
we can't use science fiction globes
anymore all of a sudden we had to come
up with like a sort of
another way of lighting the city which
had to be sort of natural light and it
couldn't be directly above the city
because a that looks super ugly as it
turns out and they if the chasm had sort
of been just this open chasm people
could have just climbed out but in
making the light source natural suddenly
nick and his team had to change where
the farm was placed and the villas and
that also means the temples
all of this done to maintain a sense of
realism and authenticity so the city
was redesigned again
once it was in place it then became
clear that something else wasn't
entirely fitting in as well as he had
intended
the characters
it started with simple name changes like
finding the roman equivalent but then
their costumes had to change so pants
and shirts became tunics and sandals
but what about the races you can't have
lizard people in ancient rome so there's
sort of these lizard people living in an
underground watery cave uh had to become
like an ancient greek philosopher and
and an african fisherman and then i
realized that like all these characters
backstories and and the reasons for how
they ended up in the forgotton city no
longer really made sense in the context
of the new sort of appearances and so on
and so yeah i'd like to essentially
change
almost every backstory this also meant
doing research into what rome was like
during the first century and then using
that as the foundation to influence the
stories the characters will tell in the
end uh the script ended up being like
twice as long as was in the beginning
and we had to re-record everything and
that meant we also had to recast
everything because you can't have
americans as ancient romans it just
doesn't work so in the end like
everything about the characters uh
changed and and i hope it had just been
it would just be the names that changed
it is done
he was wrong because changing the
characters meant changing the story and
changing the story and changing one of
the game's most defining factors
the time loop in the original mod the
loop is justified as something purely
magical but magic doesn't have any
bearing in historically authentic rome
or its mythology so after more laborious
research nick settled on the roman
goddess of renewal and rebirth which
allow the time loop to exist in the
forgotten city with authenticity and
context but what about the curse
in the original mod if anyone in the
city committed a sin everyone would burn
to death it was known as the dwarven law
this was reworked to become the golden
rule the many shall suffer
for the sins of the one of course this
dogma then needed to be manifested in
game which in turn led to entirely new
mechanics and plot lines not seen in the
original mod with the butterfly effect
that comes from making changes the
two-year endeavor to adapt the game
became a sprawling ever-growing line of
dominoes toppling into each other
creating a cascading list of challenges
to overcome with each passing day and
with each passing day nick was further
and further from any sort of backup plan
for his life
like returning to his law practice if
the game wasn't a success if i'd been
able to get the project done in two
years i might have had the option to go
back but yeah as it turns out like four
and a half years is just way too long
every time i sort of had to delay the
project or i realized it would take
longer you know i felt that slipping
away uh as an option and so yeah it was
it was definitely
anxiety-inducing and uh you know i think
i don't think i slept properly for the
entire four and a half years that i was
making it was just it was like i just
had a lot of really rough nights of
sleep by the end of it the ripple effect
of changes meant that the only course of
action was to build something all over
again from scratch it's dismantling a
house piece by piece only to realize
none of the pieces fit together anymore
it was an act of systematically undoing
years of work
what what seemed like a really
superficial change to to the setting
ended up just radically changing
everything about the the city and the
characters
um and the story and the music until all
that was really left of the original mod
was the premise and the name
it's just it's it's so wildly different
now forgotten city is a game about
making mistakes but being able to relive
the same day over and over again with
the chance to make things right and for
nick building his game from scratch is
much like the premise he had built the
game around in the first place
i got to sort of you know
rewrite the script which is now you know
twice as long and add all these new
story beats and twists and endings and
we've got all these new characters and
[Music]
in two years gamepl it just took a
really really really long time to get
there thankfully nick's career risks and
long weeks of work were not for nothing
the forgotten city officially released
as a standalone game in 2021 and was
gardened with awards all over again
including an excellence in narrative
from the australian game developer
awards talk about repeating history but
at least some things have changed for
nick i have to ask
are you sleeping better
oh yeah yeah
it's like night and day
[Music]